Speaker 1: Yesterday, President Joe Biden spoke to
the nation again about the situation in Russia and
Ukraine, with Vladimir Putin invading Ukraine on
the premise that, Hey, we've got to keep the peace
in these independent regions that I've recognized
as independent, even though they're in another
country. And we already talked yesterday
about why that entire framing doesn't make
any sense. It violates a number of different
international protocols. But the latest is,
well, what is Joe Biden going to do? And Joe
Biden is in a politically difficult situation
because no matter what he does, the right is
going to criticize him. The right is criticizing
Joe Biden. So let let's go back first. The right
attacked Biden when it came to Russia, saying, We
should want to be friends with Russia. We should.
We don't want conflict with Russia. We don't want
war with Russia. Biden, OK. But insisting that
Biden would be too harsh on Russia, whereas
Trump was more friendly and open? Yeah, we know.
Then very quickly, the right shifted to saying
Trump would have been would have been harsher
with Russia. So Putin never would have tried
this if Trump was still president. Biden is being
too weak with Russia. But then at the same time,
they're sort of defending what Vladimir
Putin is doing, saying, Yeah, you know,
Putin seems to be going to places where they
want him in. Ukraine will get to that later
and kind of defending what Vladimir Putin is
doing. And at the same time, they are saying,
well, the sanctions that Biden is putting on
Russia are not nearly strict enough. So they want
all sides of this. I want to just speak clearly
to you. Joe Biden has put in place some sanctions,
and we're going to talk about those here as
Biden yesterday, making it clear that this is an
invasion by Vladimir Putin. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Last few months, we've coordinated
closely with our NATO allies and partners
in Europe and around the world to prepare
that response. We've said all along and
I've told Putin to his face some a month,
more than a month ago, that we would act together.
And the moment Russia moved against Ukraine,
Russia is now undeniably moved against
Ukraine by declaring these independent states.
So today I'm announcing the first tranche of
sanctions to impose cost on Russia in response
to their actions yesterday. These have been
closely coordinated with our allies and partners
and will continue to escalate sanctions of Russia
as. We're implementing full blocking sanctions
on two large Russian financial institutions,
VTB and their military bank. We're implementing
comprehensive sanctions on Russian sovereign debt.
That means we've cut off Russia's government from
Western financing. It can no longer raise money
from the West and cannot trade in its new debt and
our markets or European markets, either starting
tomorrow and continuing in the days ahead. We'll
also impose sanctions on Russia's elites and their
family members they share in the corrupt gains
that the Kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well. And because of Russia's actions,
we work with Germany to ensure Nord Stream two
will not, as I promised, will not move forward
as Russia contemplates its next move. We have
our next moves prepared as well. Russia will
pay an even steeper price if it continues its
aggression, including additional sanctions.
Speaker 1: OK, and then Joe Biden going on to say
that even what he has done so far is not the full
scope of what he is willing to do. Take a look.
Speaker 2: This is the beginning of a Russian
invasion of Ukraine, as he indicated and asked
permission to be able to do from his Duma.
So let's begin to. So I'm going to
begin to impose sanctions in response,
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014.
And if Russia goes further with this invasion, we
stand prepared to go further, as with sanctions.
Speaker 1: So the big discussion, the serious
discussion, you know, all these right wing
gutter people that are just going to criticize
Biden, no matter what he does, I'm not really
interested in engaging with them. Let's let's
engage with a serious criticism, which is,
are these sanctions going far enough? And
despite repeating that the U.S. won't send
troops to Ukraine, is the U.S. basically fighting
this as a proxy war? So let's take these two
questions one by one. First of all, are the
sanctions put in place by the United States?
That strict? And the answer is sorta, but
not really. One of the real concerns about
the very first set of sanctions was you're really
just sanctioning the regions that Putin invaded.
You're not really hitting Russians and Russia
directly now with the sanctioning of Russian banks
and more Russian billionaires and their families
and their assets and ability to move assets,
you are more directly hitting Russia proper.
But you could go a lot further. Why isn't Biden
doing it? Well, you'd have to ask him why
he's not doing it, but it makes sense that
you've got to keep something off the you've
got to keep something on the table. Rather,
in case Putin goes further because there
is speculation at this point, and so far,
most of the speculation has been borne out to be
accurate in terms of what Putin has done so far.
There's speculation that Putin's ambitions are
greater than the Donetsk and Luhansk regions that
so far he has sent troops to. If Putin wants to
push further into Ukraine up to and including the
Ukrainian capital Kiev, and wants to try to effect
regime change installing a puppet government
who knows what Putin's ambitions are, you need to
leave something more on the table geopolitically
and from a foreign relations standpoint.
It makes sense you don't do everything yet
because you suspect Putin has not done everything
yet. So we are getting to harsher sanctions.
And it and it is logical to not go fully out
because you've got to be able to bring down more
if and when Vladimir Putin pushes further
into Ukraine. Now on the proxy war question,
I think we just have to accept that this time that
the U.S. is waging a proxy war against Russia now,
sometimes by proxy war, we mean both parties are
using proxies. In this case, it is Russia pushing
into Ukraine and the U.S. using Naito sanctions
and arming of Ukraine and supporting Ukraine as
a proxy to fighting Russia directly. And proxy
wars are not objectively good or bad, but we
have to recognize that while Joe Biden has said
we're not going to put boots on the ground, we're
not dropping, we're not using drones. And at least
for the time being, we're not doing cyber attacks
on Russia. We are engaged in a sort of war here
and that is not an endorsement or a criticism,
but it is a reality and that is something that
we're going to discuss more on tomorrow's program